what did the weird bet Oh there's quite
a few profits coming in this week let's
start off with the first song that's
gonna be performed this is an actual bed
night this is an actual bet you can make
that J Lo's first song will be what the
odds are four plus four hundred which
means if you bet a hundred dollars you
win $400 it's going to be on the floor
[Music]
you must like this JD because it's like
EDM okay I don't I don't like a lot of
like singing with the the electronic
music I'm ready to sing so
[Music]
on the floor on the floor
[Music]
go ahead so is pitbull coming well
there's a prop for that I think
pitbulls coming pitbull shows up on
stage during halftime -200 yes plus 150
I said take that bet
yeah but wouldn't pitbull like bet on
himself if he knew like how do you keep
him from betting on himself they don't
let you bet like a million dollars you
could get inside information but that DJ
Khalid is he dropped for him all other
one is will a rod be shown during the
half I say no I'll say 50 they don't
show a rod during the actual part
another JLo prop yeah will you see butt
cleavage no yes or no you mean ass crack
no - 404 no plus 254 yes I say no but
most people think now yeah no I like
maybe you see the bottom of cheeks under
shorts but I don't think you're gonna
see that either yeah let's jump over to
Shakira real quick cuz you could better
her first song as well and you've got a
column there she wolf is the favour to
plus 250 that's the first this is the
favorite yes
[Music]
whatever wherever is +400 like what does
that mean if I bet a hundred bucks
you'll win 400 if I hit that that seems
like I should get a lot more money if I
can predict Shakira's playlist for tawan
is what they say all right so let me
hear I think there's a good shot the
next one plus 600 hips don't lie
no she's gonna wait on that no she has
little time yeah you always try to
finish she's a part of it she's not it's
not J dude you're gonna lose money go
ahead and bet it so why don't you make a
bet my song should carry those come on
put your money where your mouth is God
knows where your mouth I'll go with you
no all right I'll go fifty with you all
right
no way hips no lies our first alright so
Howard and Robin fifty gave me action
are you want action - I'll give Robin
action that was fire duty you won those
edibles margarita yeah I actually see
his logic in this John I win it's gonna
be in the middle of J Lo's performance
she's gonna come in or you think she's
gonna want to really uh those horns
maybe you got a point e away I could
lose for JLo - change outfits you see a
Doritos at first or a pop-tarts at first
I'll take torito's 400 bucks I think the
newsboy wouldn't say I'll take pop tart
alright how much 50 Edie why do you want
in I kind of like it a little bit what
do you think
I think Doritos will well sure I know
they would Robin all right Robin if you
want action on that okay were you taking
- Reese I'm taking Doritos so we're both
mark that both going against Robin are
smart bad I took it let's do Most
Valuable Player so I'm not even going to
name the players because I won't waste
time
[Music]
sorry did how much well I took a few I
bet Travis Kelce for $5 if I win I win a
hundred and twenty-five who's the
favorite Holmes yeah he's almost even
but what you bet on my Holmes you won't
win as much if he gets it but you're
taking the long shot yeah and I took a
guy that's on defense Tyrann Mathieu the
honey badger I bet to $2 on him if I win
I get a hundred and twenty-two so it's
like I might as well run the dough for
two jokes this is my favourite MVP woman
who'll he first mentioned in his speech
teammates god or religion the city that
he plays in god the coach family or a
family member or the owner of the team I
would take teammates on this teammates
is the favorite ever take teammates
because I think my homes
I think the Chiefs are gonna win yeah I
think my home is gonna be the MVP and he
is a team player that's his rat and I'm
going teammates on my homes yeah I'll
take God really yeah you say my homes
will thank God before he thinks I don't
think my homes gonna win the MVP but if
he done right I still think God's a
better bet 50 bucks done nice I'm in the
money last one we got is the game itself
Kansas City is favored by one and a half
points over the San Francisco 49ers hmm
gotta go chiefs I know nothing III think
I'm gonna bet the Chiefs well I was
gonna take the Chiefs so they'd lose
I'll take the 49ers oh yeah I'll give
you another 50 on another 50 all right
John any more or you die alrighty I'll
take your cheese 450 looks like I'm on
my own with the 49ers I'm looking to
Gary how about how many shrimp will Gary
before have